[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVE BAZYL: Hi, everyone, and
thanks for joining us today.
I'm Stephen Bazyl and today we
are joined with a special
guest, Brett van Zuiden
from filepicker.io.
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN:
How's it going?
STEVE BAZYL: Great.
So today we're going
to do two things.
Actually, three things.
We have a recap of last week's
Google I/O, then we're going
to talk a little bit about
filepicker and some of the
great work you've been doing
with Cloud APIs and where
things are going.
And we're also going to do a
review of one of the apps that
was actually at I/O in
the sandbox, Magisto.
So let's get started with I/O.
So, Brett, you actually were
at I/O.
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: I was.
I thought it was fantastic.
Definitely a lot of the cool new
stuff coming out, not only
new functionality on the web,
but also some sort of sneak
peeks into where we're driving
and the rest of the Google
products are going.
STEVE BAZYL: Any particular
highlights?
Things that were
your favorites?
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: The web
components has been something
I've been watching for awhile,
and the request autocomplete
was actually a new
thing I hadn't
seen that got me excited.
STEVE BAZYL: Very cool.
I like the web components.
I'm a big fan of [? agular, ?]
I love where all that stuff
is going as well.
So on the drive side, most of
our talks are now available
online on the
Developers.google.com/live and
on YouTube.
We'll put together a playlist
of all the drive sessions
sometime this week so that
you'll be able to find our
sessions pretty easily.
There are a lot of great ones.
One from Ali Afshar about using
the app data for syncing
preferences on Android.
And they actually open sourced
a library that was built for
that demo, and it's really
cool and getting a lot of
interest already.
Brian and Cheryl also did a
great talk on the real time
API that is well worth watching
if you're interested
in using that API.
The sandbox was a great hit.
We had 24 different vendors
come into the Google I/O
sandbox for those three days.
Some of those were for Google
Drive, some were with Apps
Script and also the new Gmail
feature for having actions.
Some really great demos and
we're actually going to talk
about one of those later
later today.
This is Magisto, a really,
really awesome video editing
app that talks to Drive.
And Carrie will do
a demo and walk
through that pretty quickly.
In terms of product
announcements, we didn't
announce too much yet, but
there's a lot in store for the
next couple weeks.
One thing we did talk about
earlier, before I/O, was
storage unification.
So now your storage, for
Google Drive, is shared
between Gmail and your Google+
photo attachments.
And we have, again, we have a
lot of cool stuff coming up in
the next few weeks.
So let's talk about
filepicker.io.
So for those who don't know it,
can you give a little bit
of a background about what
you've been working on--
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: Sure.
STEVE BAZYL: --and what you're
trying to solve for
developers.
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: Of course.
So one thing that we're noticing
with the migration of
content from the local devices
to online, for me at least,
and for a lot of users, that
Cloud is sort of the default
hard drive.
It's the default place
where people are
storing their content.
That's everything from services
like Google+ and
Facebook and Instagram for their
photos, to Drive and
Dropbox, Inbox, for things
like documents.
Even things like Gmail
attachments.
And so what we wanted to do was
say, let's provide a way
for developers to hook into all
these different sources
and to provide that choice for
their users and to be able to
access that wherever
their users are
storing their content.
And so, obviously, a lot of
the Google services play a
pretty central role in that,
not only Drive, but also
Picasa and then Gmail
attachments, but also making
sure that we connect into some
of these and the other Cloud
services like Box and Dropbox.
And so we really tried to put
those all together in a nice
package for developers so that
they can say, hey, I want a
profile image and I want an
image and it really doesn't
matter to me where that image
comes from, whether it comes
from the webcam or somewhere
online or even the hard drive.
So we bundle that up for them,
provide it a nice clean API
and we take care of the rest.
STEVE BAZYL: Sounds awesome.
You want to show a demo?
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: Sure thing.
So here you'll see this is
pretty much as simple as it
gets here with the command.
So it is a fully
JavaScript API.
We also have an API on Android
and iOS that's fairly similar,
but just to show it here, so the
command filepicker.pick,
you give us a callback function
and we had you back
some data along with the
URL to the file.
So here that's all the code
that's necessary.
So here now, if I go
and say OK, great.
Let's figure out--
OK, this is a pretty
good document here.
I'm going to upload this and
then we hand back a URL.
And now this will actually point
directly to the content.
We'll also do things like store
it on S3 for you, sort
of handle a bunch of
the other common
actions that people want.
But for instance, if we wanted
to say OK, what does this look
like if we specifically
want images?
So if we say we want
the mime type to be
image/jpeg say, great.
Run this, and now the selections
will be limited
just to the jpeg images.
So now, if I go here, I select
this-- oh, see, PNGs are not
allowed, I should have known
that was going to happen here.
But close this.
We'll say we do actually
want that PNG.
Go to Developers Live.
Here we go.
And uploaded successfully.
So now we can take this--
and this is a fully
functioning URL.
This points directly
to the data.
So that now you get this
and, it's successful.
So that is full demo of the
pick functionality.
There is also storing and
saving out to the Cloud.
STEVE BAZYL: And you have a
similar functionality for
mobile as well, right?
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: We do.
STEVE BAZYL: Android and iOS?
Very cool.
That is probably about as easy
as it gets to integrate with
Cloud storage.
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: That's
what we try.
And a few things here that we
really believe, one is I'm
doing this all on
a Chromebook.
And I think that really exposes
some of the power and
some of the sort of movement
that we're seeing.
I have access to everything that
I need on this Chromebook
even if it's not sitting
directly on the
device's hard drive.
Also, you notice, we passed
around these URLs and one of
the things that we think we
provide a lot of value in is
going from a pass-by value
architecture where, whenever
you want to transfer content
between Google Drive and your
application, or even from
the hard drive and your
application, it's all
done by sending
these big blobs around.
And so you have to configure
your load balance or an engine
x and all those things, whereas
for us, we turn it
into a URL for you.
We handle all that and then you
can pass that URL around,
you can store that in your
database, and it becomes much
easier to handle.
STEVE BAZYL: Definitely
the way to go.
So your whole product is an API,
and I was just curious
what lessons you had for people
who maybe there's other
areas for services-- maybe not
files-- but other areas of
technology where really the
product is an API offering.
And what did you learn in the
past few years as you got
started and what advice for
the next filepicker.io?
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: I'll start
with some of the fun things
and then get into, I
guess, some of the
more tangible things.
.io is actually a great domain
name for signaling that you're
a developer product.
We, in some of our initial
outreach back before people
had heard of us, we'd send
emails to people and at first
they'd be like, well, I looked
at the email, I thought it
might just be some spammy
business person sending it and
then I saw the .io and I was
like, ah, these guys are
developers.
.io, especially for us, it's
input, output, Google I/O,
things like that.
So in terms of more on the
business and strategy side,
it's really important that
customer support stands first
and foremost.
When people--
and that goes everything from
having great documentation to
having real people available
to email.
So one of things that we still
do is whenever someone signs
up we send them an email from a
real person, we assign them
to a developer that says, I'm
here to help you get started.
And for a lot of people, whether
they're just trying it
out or whether they're building
it into their
production app, that really
goes a long way.
STEVE BAZYL: I definitely
agree.
I've actually talked to a few
of those people and everyone
has been super awesome
on your team.
So I love everything
filepicker.io is doing.
I think it's a great
way to get started.
One of the concerns, for me at
least, is it tends to bring
all the APIs down to the lowest
common denominator.
And I was wondering, what
advice do you have for
developers in terms of how do
they make that decision as to
whether or not they use
something like filepicker.io--
which is great for reaching a
lot of users really quickly--
versus going very deep into
one of the particular
providers and taking advantage
of some of the
more advanced features?
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: Sure.
STEVE BAZYL: How do
you guide people?
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: So we try to
aim for what we call the
middle common denominator.
So we'll do things where we'll
sort of up-level some of APIs
that aren't as good and provide
the functionality that
makes them at least sort
of on par with average.
We find though, is if you're
building a real time document
collaboration, service, things
like that, of course, there
are really those core APIs that
you need to leverage.
That's great and we want
to encourage that.
What we really find is we're
sort of going for the broad
use case where people are
saying, really what I want is
I just want to be able to
import content to my
application, or allow the
user to save it out.
And there's all I sort of want
is a chunk of data and for
that I think that we can provide
that very easily.
One of the things that we see,
that we've worked with a lot
of people on, is if they need to
do folder level operations
or commenting, there's a lot of
richness in the Drive APIs,
as well as some of
these other APIs.
For instance, we don't expose
Facebook tags and things like
that to sort of unify
them together.
So they're definitely
situations where
I say, go for it.
Use the traditional APIs.
But if you can get away with
saying, hey, really we just
want the content.
I think we can provide
that need for you.
STEVE BAZYL: And in terms of
adoption and growth, things
are looking good.
We're certainly seeing Drive
growing like crazy.
I hope things are looking
on your end as well.
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN: They are.
It's very exciting.
It's one of these things now
where we're starting to reach
out and hit rate limits.
It's fun, though.
It's a lot of fun and we
keep cranking along.
STEVE BAZYL: Awesome.
Stay tuned.
I'm going to turn it
over to Carrie.
She is going to talk about
really cool app, Magisto, and
show some of the inner workings
of Google life here.
CARRIE ROWE: Hi everybody,
I'm Carrie Rowe.
I'm on the Drive dev-rel team
and I was at the Google I/O
the past week, and one of the
apps that I was blown away by
in our sandbox was this
app called Magisto.
And what they do, it's a video
editing software app.
And I take tons of video on my
Android phone, like minutes
and minutes of video every week,
and I never look at it
and I never share it
with people because
it's just not watchable.
So what Magisto does is it will
automatically video edit
your videos for you
and it makes it
really easy and magical.
So let's take a look.
So I'm on the Magisto website
and let's go.
And what's great about--
let's see, continue.
What's great about Magisto is
it's integrated with our
Google Drive products and so I
can select my videos directly
from Google Drive.
So right here you see on their
front page, I can either
select a file from my computer
or I can select a file
directly from the Cloud.
And so I've taken a whole bunch
of videos and I created
one yesterday with our
dev-rel team right
here playing Foozball.
And so I'm going to select my
video and then the next step
is I can select the background
that I want.
And they have all these
really great
pre-edited background styles.
So let's go with the
street beats.
And then the next step, once you
have your background, is
you can choose any music
that you want to add.
So they're making every step
really, really easy for you to
make a really great video.
So let's see, let's
go with Lady Gaga.
And then the third step is you
just hit Create, and it's as
easy as that.
And so I've already created
the video, so
let's take a look.
And so yesterday I created about
a minute long video of
our team playing Foozball.
So you can see that
it's taken--
it's now shortened it into
a 30 second video.
And what it's done
is it's selected
all of the best clips.
So I know I'm not a professional
videographer, so
when I take lots of video there
tends to be a lot of
dead time and parts that
aren't as interesting.
So it really creates
and condenses it
into the best content.
And it adds in, you saw, the
backgrounds of all the text
and images.
And then you can add music
to it as well.
And then when you're done, you
can share it with your friends
and family.
So this is a really great app to
help you access your videos
more and share them
with everybody.
And that's it for our
app of the week.
And I'll turn it back to Steve
now to talk a little bit about
what we have in store
for you next week.
STEVE BAZYL: Thanks.
And I do believe my team
actually won that game.
We did get interrupted with a
freak quad copter accident
during that but it was actually
a fun game and a
great serendipitous moment.
So for next week we are going
to be here talking about how
you can work for Google
Developer Relations.
We're going to talk about
recruiting, some of the
activities that we do, things
like I/O and, of course, the
Google Developer Live
broadcasts and other
activities.
And for those who are interested
in applying, we
will let you know
how that process
works and what to expect.
One other announcement, that I
forgot to do earlier, was we
actually have a winner
for a raspberry pie.
And this is somebody who posted
to Google+ with an
interesting anagram of the
Google Drive SDKs, which
turned out to be Desk
Evil Do Grogg.
And so it's K Powell Palmisano,
hopefully I got
that correct.
We will reach out to you on
the community and get your
contact information so we can
send you a raspberry pie.
And we'll have some more
opportunities for people to
get those in the future so, of
course, stay tuned and join
the community.
And join in next week and learn
more about what life is
like at Google Developer
Relations.
Brett, thank you very much for
joining us here today.
I know we have lots of cool
stuff that you can do together
in the future to make it even
easier for developers, so look
forward to seeing
how things go.
BRETT VAN ZUIDEN:
You and me both.
Thanks for having me.
STEVE BAZYL: All right.
And thank you Carrie for the
awesome review on Magisto.
CARRIE ROWE: You're welcome.
Thanks for watching, guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]